- Depuis quelques mois,
Montréal-Nord est aux prises
avec une vague de violence
liée aux gangs armés.
Sur les 26 homicides commis
à Montréal depuis janvier, 4 ont
été commis dans le quartier.
SOPHIE HÉBERT,
résidente de Montréal-Nord
- Personnellement, moi, j'ai
à coeur de rendre ses lettres
de noblesse à Montréal-Nord et,
oui, c'est sûr que d'entendre
des choses comme ça, ça
m'inquiète pour la réputation.
- Cette mère de famille
a emménagé dans le quartier
il y quatre ans.
- Initialement, on regardait
d'autres secteurs, en toute
honnêteté. On regardait d'autres
secteurs qui étaient beaucoup
trop chers pour la qualité qu'on
pouvait retrouver des maisons.
- À la hauteur de Fleury,
Gouin...
- Courtier immobilier
qui travaille dans le nord
de la ville, Gaston Crevier
est persuadé que les récentes
fusillades refroidissent
des acheteurs potentiels.
Il a fait l'exercice de comparer
les prix de maisons de cinq rues
de part et d'autre de la
frontière qui sépare
Ahuntsic et Montréal-Nord.
GASTON CREVIER,
courtier immobilier
- De l'autre côté de la rue,
c'est Montréal-Nord puis il y a
un impact direct sur les prix.
T'sais, cinq rues à l'est
versus cinq rues à l'ouest,
il va y avoir un 13 % souvent
de différenciation de valeur
sur les plex. Pourtant, c'est
le même quartier, tout le monde
habite à la même place,
les enfants vont à l'école
au même endroit.
- L'Association professionnelle
des courtiers immobiliers
du Québec observe une hausse
des nouvelles inscriptions
en 2021 à Montréal-Nord.
Les propriétaires sont donc
plus nombreux à vouloir quitter
le quartier. Néanmoins,
les maisons s'y vendent
plus rapidement et à des prix
plus avantageux qu'ailleurs
à Montréal.
DENIS JOANIS, prés., Association
prof., courtiers immobiliers, Qc
- Il est vraiment trop tôt
pour tirer cette conclusion-là.
Je suis persuadé que
ça ne peut pas durer longtemps,
que ça va se replacer.
- Chercheur à la Faculté
de l'aménagement de l'Université
de Montréal, Jean-Philippe
Meloche observe que, depuis
les années 90, Montréal a
été relativement épargnée par
les vagues de criminalité que
connaissent les grandes
villes du continent.
JEAN-PHILIPPE MELOCHE, Faculté
de l'aménagement de l'U. de Mtl
- À Montréal, on n'est pas
habitués à cette situation-là.
Le nombre d'homicides par
arme à feu annuellement
est relativement faible
si on compare aux autres
villes d'Amérique du Nord,
même à Toronto. Mais quand
on va aux États-Unis, c'est
souvent multiplié par dix.
Oui, c'est inquiétant de
se demander si on n'est pas
en train de faire un rattrapage.
Quand les gens se sentent trop
exclus puis, éventuellement,
ça se transforme en criminalité
ou en désorganisation sociale,
si on veut, bien, c'est là que
les quartiers peuvent
devenir stigmatisés.
- L'organisme Hoodstock
travaille justement à
combattre les inégalités
dans l'arrondissement.
CASSANDRA EXUMÉ, coordonnatrice
générale, Hoodstock
- Il faut absolument pas
banaliser les inquiétudes des
gens. Par contre, Montréal-Nord,
pour nous, c'est beaucoup plus
que ça. Il faut que les gens
viennent dans le quartier
se faire une idée par eux-mêmes.
C'est un exemple d'un quartier
qui représente cette force
mondiale, dans le fond.
Quand on se diversifie
puis on s'unit, on amène les
citoyens, on amène un quartier
à un autre niveau.
- Cette diversité à Montréal-
Nord, on la voit partout,
alors que plus de 40 %
de la population est issue
de l'immigration, une richesse
qui encourage Sophie Hébert
à demeurer dans le quartier.
- Il y a beaucoup plus de beauté
qu'il y a de criminalité selon
moi. J'en parle à plein de gens
autour de moi qui cherchent
des maisons. Puis je leur dis :
Venez voir le secteur!
Parce qu'il y a vraiment des
belles choses intéressantes.
Donc, je pense que les gens vont
être capables d'aller au-delà.
Mais est-ce c'est dans
les prochains mois? Je sais pas.
- Ici Simon Coutu,
Radio-Canada,